I looked to the side of the Qatar and
she had a jar with things in it clitoris
Libya everything that she has cut
previously I looked at it and I thought
I'm gonna die and then being sewn
whilst you are fully awake is one
experience that I don't think I will
ever forget
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives I'm joined today by
shamsa uh shamsa if you could give a
brief introduction to yourself
my name is shamsa also known as
shamsarawela I am a survivor of a female
genital mutilation
and that's what we're going to talk
about today and I'm also an educator and
I'm and a fabulous activist
I love it I like the uh I like The
Fabulous Fit yeah it really brings it to
life activism is fabulous okay yes well
today we're going to talk about
um some very sensitive topics and some
very dark topics yeah and uh I just want
to say to you up front that you know I'm
learning here as well so please do
educate me and correct me if I ask
anything in an insensitive way or if I
use the wrong language or anything like
that more than happy to understand how
to correctly talk about this topic of
course I'll be on it okay so at the
beginning there you mentioned female
genital mutilation yes
um can you tell us what that is uh
female genital mutilation is a practice
that has existed it predates both
Christianity and Islam it is a procedure
where a young girl is
has her genitals cut ultimately
um there are four types
type one is the removal of the clitoris
um
either partly or fully part there type 2
is the removal of the clitoris in the
labia Menorah and in both type 1 and
type 2 they can also be sold
together
type 3 is the most severe type of female
genital mutilation and it is when the
clitoris the labia and the labia majora
is cut and then the person is the young
girl is sewn together and then so when
them shots leaving small holes for
urination and period flow there's also
Type 4 which includes
um
pricking burning scrape anything that
damages or changes the female genitalia
so yeah and that that is female genital
mutilation and is that evident I mean
this sounds like a stupid question but
is that evident for health reasons or is
what is the reason there is absolutely
no health benefits to female genital
mutilation at all it is a cultural
practice
um that is really really harmful to the
young girls who have experienced it and
from the age they undergo the procedure
up to
when you know they pass away they are a
lot you know older they have there's a
lot of complications
um that is involved a lot of which can
cause serious health uh risks whether
that be you know through pregnancy the
period the just as simple as even
urination can get really complicated
um and painful and
difficult so so why do people do it
um it is a cultural practice that has
you know like I said it pre-dates both
Islam and Christianity so it is
something that has existed at first like
I believe they used to do it on mummies
in Egypt
um after they have died
and then it was done to slave women in
Egypt and then it just became a
widespread practice all over Africa Asia
and the world really is it just
tradition like why why do this thing to
people and there are many reasons uh one
of the reasons is religious which is
absolutely berserk is does that's not
true at all religion has nothing to do
with it
um
[Music]
right I say yes they do in the name of
religion also
um a lot of cultures do it because
they're trying to prevent either rape
sexual harassment
um or you know any type of sexual abuse
others do it so that their daughter
doesn't have sex before marriage and
some do it because you know your
daughter is not going to be marryable if
she does not have the procedure done wow
um so there are many many factors also
there's an um Financial Factor
that's their job that's where they get
money
so you can imagine it's it's a very
diffic is going to be a very difficult
practice to
you know stop it's not going to stop
with a click of a finger because there
are so many elements
um that are in play and you know some
people it's become social Norm yes that
makes sense yes and when something is a
social Norm you will not see
you know unless someone tells you
otherwise you're going to accept it and
you're going to be okay with it because
well that yeah that's a very good
jumping off point to the next thing I
wanted to ask because you were born in
Somalia is that correct yes now I want
to be careful here because obviously
this we're going to talk about cultures
and different you know different
traditions and different things like
that and I just want to be careful that
we we talk fairly about
uh different geographical locations and
different cultures
um but when you were growing up in
Somalia
were you aware of this practice and were
you aware that it was something that
would happen to you eventually or did it
happen to some people or was did it
happen to every girl and it was just a
rite of passage like what was your
understanding of it as a child
um we were taught we were told about it
at a very young age I lived with my
grandmother at 12 or 11 other siblings
or 12. we grew up in the same house
um it was half girls and half boys
and all the girls who were older than us
had already had it done my aunties and
my grandma and every single female I
have ever come across growing up has had
the procedure done
so the whole entire Community
knowing that you're coming off you know
that is coming up to that age where
you're about to have it done and what
age is that it can be from
I'll say three oh my God until usually
for some people it's zero until oh my
God everything wow but it can go up to
at the age of 21. so I assumed it was
more of a like a puberty thing but yeah
you know they do it before puberty okay
right yeah because I think then it would
be a lot harder for the girl to
um accept it yeah sure you know so there
was an awareness in the house with your
aunt yeah sisters no there was a massive
awareness and when it came down to when
we were having it done they slowly you
know started telling us or you're gonna
have good tan that's what they called it
and because we already heard it and
every girl that we asked prior was so
happy about it right it was as if it was
false advertisement that's what it was
yeah but it's almost done so that you
are convinced
beforehand that is okay and it's
something to look forward to and it's a
riot of Passage and you know we you're
gonna become a woman so we were really
excited I was me and my siblings were as
excited as we would have been if we were
getting our
um is pissed wow and you were four I was
six six okay so you and your siblings
were varying in age but you were six I
was six and you were all gonna get it
done at the same time or you're right at
the same time but why why then would you
why would some be older and some be
younger going into that procedure you
know you were six and then presumably
some were a little bit older some so my
sister was seven yeah and my cousin was
five right so we were just a year older
okay from each other
um but again as you can see it is five
six they just decided everyone's ready
now yes okay so um
do you mind telling us about it of
course
of course
um I remember I was we were playing you
know being kids and my grandma
approached us and said uh to you know
we're gonna have gudetan
then we got excited we were told that we
I was gonna have it down with my sister
or my cousin and we went willingly to my
grandma's house where the cutter was
waiting oh so it's just like we're doing
it now yeah wow I think it was maybe a
day before we were told okay
um so where we arrived at my
um Grandma's house there was a woman sat
on a very very small
um chair in the in the front yard of my
auntie's house so but it was gated
so there were Gates around it but we
don't have backyards we have front yards
and um
we waited patiently we me and my cousin
my sister sat together
and then
my cousin was told to go first and she
skipped you know to because she's a
child that she was a lot younger than us
she went to the chair and
the moment she sat down and made contact
with that chair there was my grandma my
aunt two aunties an uncle uh plaster
cutter I don't remember who else was
there
and I remember
the moment she sat down adults were
grabbing her limbs her legs her arms and
trying to you know each hold on to one
and to keep her down so me and my sister
are looking at each other like what yeah
what is going on because that's not
something that we expected we went the
procedure was never described to us how
they said to you it'll hurt a little bit
no nothing nothing so you just thought
it was a good purely positive experience
okay and then I remember
the Qatar taking something out and it's
one of those small double-sided raises
and
but we couldn't physically see the razor
so when she started cutting her
genitalia
all we saw was blood and my cousin
screaming at the top of her lung oh my
God and then they took a material and
kinda to muffle her screams they tied it
um behind her head so that they could
focus on holding down her Limbs and I
think what is really really important
for everyone to know is this was done
with our anesthetics
this was done without any painkillers
this was done
outside a house probably with the same
razor that they used on somebody else
before she turned up to the house
and when we saw that being the person I
was I was like ah this is not gonna
happen to me and me and my sister ran
we ran and because we were children
there was so many people in the house so
we were they chased after us they bought
us back and we had to sit there until
she was sewn completely shot
and still screaming in tears you know
asking for help pleading
and then I was told to go next
I refused and bear in mind that chair
that had blood and everything it still
stayed we all got caught in on the same
chair
and then I was dragged to that seat
because I refused to sit down peacefully
and because of again because of the type
of child I was I would not rest
I did not you know allow it I tried to
almost levitate of the
um of the chair but they held with all
of their mights and their Force they
held me down
who is holding you at this point my
family
you trust yeah
pretty much
and um
she started cutting and when the blade
touched my skin
it was like nothing I've ever felt
before it was extremely extremely
painful and again I'm fighting you know
um so it was very difficult for them to
you know they were struggling holding me
down and then they put a cloth over my
mouth because of this screaming
and I remember
at some point my whole entire body went
into complete shock I just went
almost numb for a little bit and I
looked to the side of the Qatar and she
had a jar
with things in it obviously now I know
that what those bits are
clitoris Libya Mojo everything that she
has cut previously because all of that
didn't come from my cousin
um
I looked at it and I thought I'm gonna
die I genuinely thought I was gonna die
the pain was so overwhelming
um
you you don't know what to do
as a child and you just kind of
freeze but also fight and it's trying to
scream but you can't because you know
your mouth is covered and it was very
very painful
and then being sewn
whilst you are fully awake is one
experience that I don't think I will
ever forget in my life
um
I saw things now so can you I just
imagining doing that to a human being is
the most inhumane thing ever and to have
experienced that myself
it
I don't even know how to describe it to
be honest with you it's a needle
constantly going you know through you
until you are completely shocked and
then they leave it they left a small
hole where the urination
um the urine Hall is originally meant to
be and then they left us another small
Hall uh in the where the vaginal opening
is
um for period flow and
um
penetration in the future
and as soon as they were done they tied
our legs together
um like literally tied our legs together
with a cloth and then picked us up
because we weren't allowed to walk past
down on the floor and then we had to
unable to turn away unable to walk
unable to run we had I had to watch my
sister get it done near my cousin
while she was done they also tied her
legs put her next to us and then the
most unusual thing is every culture does
FGM differently so I'm celebrated
um others is more forceful in some cases
it's a hospital setting so it varies
um but in my case I don't know whether
they've done it because of the shock I
don't know the reason behind it to be
honest but they slaughter that animal
prior
and then they washed they covered all of
us in the blood and we had to stand and
you know Africa is really hot so we had
to stand
um
you know with our legs tight until we
dried and then once we dry they washed
the blood of us and it's the most
disgusted thing I have ever experienced
and bear in mind the blood is touching
the wound that's just
um
you know
the procedure that has just happened to
you it's it's just horrific it's
horrible horrible horrible
and then I I especially remember wanting
to urinate afterwards
and the stinging
the pain
and it didn't have anywhere to come out
from really so it took a very very long
time for me to urinate which meant a
very very long time right after the
procedure I had to
you know urinate but it wasn't coming
out properly which meant longer pain
um
and we had our legs tied for a few weeks
a few weeks a few weeks yeah we were
taken to the toilet we were carried
everywhere
um and then
because they scared that the stitches
will come off and if they do I would
they would have to redo it yeah okay so
because we were all afraid of having it
redone
um I think they
insured made sure that none of the
stitches came out
and eventually when they did untie us it
was very difficult as you know walking
and
um running you know you're a kid you
want to run around you know you can't do
that
um it took a few good months
for it to not heal fully but he'll
enough for us to start playing and
almost kind of forgot about it I know it
sounds really unusual but because it was
a social Norm yeah
let's say it's like you know if you
complained although we didn't
because by that point we were terrified
of our families yeah me and my sister I
think genuinely thought we would they
were going to kill us because we thought
this isn't this is a normal and from
then on I think there was a massive fear
um installed into us against our own
family so I wanted to ask about that
because
what you've just described is a utterly
horrific like it's unbelievably awful
yeah
how was it that people from your family
could go through that and then be
telling you it's a good thing afterwards
yeah
because it's normally happened to them
but you wouldn't have done that you
wouldn't have gone through that and then
told other people yeah yeah it's good
you should do it to be honest I probably
would have right if I lived there okay
if I had lived imagine you live in a
place where
you know
um this procedure takes place there is
no way that you can disagree yeah and
the purpose of kind of making it sound
nice is so that to kind of not
traumatize the child I know it sounds
stupid but they don't want to create
fear so the child can run away they can
go into hiding they can refuse if they
actually described it so it was down to
you know the whole village because it
wasn't just up to my parents or not my
parents my grandma in terms of raising
meals you know it's like more of a
village raising you and everyone in that
Village will had a responsibility not to
tell the truth really ultimately
um it was I don't think there is anyone
in that particular Village that went
uncircumcised because it would be seen
as shameful
and was it was it was it quite a strict
culture like if you said that was a
horrible thing to happen and I think we
shouldn't do it anymore would that have
been something that was just impossible
to yeah they won't have listened yeah
they would have been they would have
come up with the excuses you know it's
religious reasons yeah is to make you
cleaner and then what can you say to
that as a young child yeah you know as
an adult uh who's telling you this is
good for you and you know there's a
reason and there's a purpose and it's
you know for us especially they said
that it was a religious
um requirement
so we just we accepted it and that's
literally how easy it is for
um a child growing up and not in any
country that performs FGM they just
agree and go along with their trusted
family members until that trust is
broken
when the procedure takes place and you
at that point that you tell it you just
said you were basically now terrified of
your family
yeah
naturally so I think um is that what led
you to want to move away or was that a
different set of circumstances because I
guess what I'm wondering is at that
point what you're describing is as a
child
despite how utterly horrific it was you
were still in the position where you're
going okay everyone's saying this is
normal so I guess this is life yeah what
was the point where you you thought you
realized
something was different
it was when I came to this country and
how did you come about moving to this
country so my mom at the time of my FGM
procedure she was actually against it
because she had suffered so much
complications
but my mother wasn't in the country she
was in Saudi and she was working towards
getting us a visa to come to the UK
um knowing the risks of being in that
country she was you know kind of wanted
to reunite all of us I did not see my
mom then until since I was a baby I was
raised by my grandma so
when my mother came to get us
again we didn't talk about it I don't
know whether she addressed that
situation with my grandma but we didn't
talk about it because it's not something
to you know we're told to talk about is
actually considered AB which means
shameful to talk about oh right so it's
not just an open conversation no right
okay it's not an open conversation so
your mother came back to Somalia to
collect the children and bring them to
the UK yes
and we came sorry what age were you here
I was I think I had just turned seven
okay so still young it's still young by
then he had healed
and
I remember we were in Ethiopia and I was
still struggling to urinate it was
really really painful and
again we never ever spoke about it it
was almost like it's done now so you
know what can we do because they didn't
know there were any other options you
know like surgery or things like that
So eventually my father was in this
country he um successfully applied for
our Visa it got accepted and then we
came to the UK
and
I we moved into London
and I remember
coming here and thinking you know it was
a whole new world and when you're there
you're told so many things negative
mostly about Western Society all right
yeah like women are naked they know what
they are
um without faith you know and you know
just things that choose they probably
misinterpreted in on you know on TV so
was it a bit scary for you moving here
it was I was terrified I drank I
remember I drank uh was it cocoa Pepsi
for the first time and I thought it was
alcohol and I was like no I don't want
it but I remember my mom laughing her
head off and she said no because I came
from a very very small village they
didn't have any of that and it took a
quite a while for me to adjust
and then
I believe two years later I had my
period so I was nine when I got my
period I felt like I was being tested
and when again that's another thing
um the Somali Community do not talk
about is periods especially with their
daughters
um we just find out the day that it
comes and then with the majority of us
think we're dying what so there's no
education no like wow no I genuinely
thought I was I was dying yeah
um and I remember my mum laughing and
she said no no you're not dying don't
worry
um but I was told I was showing how to
use a pad
but I don't think my FGM was ever
considered
um because again they have lived what
they consider a normal life even though
they've had FGM so we should do you know
we should do that too
and I my mother told me that I should
never share it with anybody the fact
that I've had my period don't tell
anyone not my father not my sister no
one so I had to I don't know it was I
think it's because you're considered a
woman when you get your period
so
um I don't think she wants it
anyone to consider me that way or
suggest you know or because this is just
marriage quite young in some cases so I
don't know what she was afraid of for
her to tell me that she never told me
the reason why
um
but I kept it to myself I used I
remember
every single month for the next three
four years I used to roll from one side
of the room to the other because it was
so painful
the period had absolutely nowhere to
come out
because you're completely shocked you
know you're left a tiny hole there's no
there's not much blood that's going to
flow
um especially considering
um you know your your son
together so does it come out but just
extremely slowly extremely slowly so it
accumulates inside of the woman and for
some women it just doesn't come out so
every month it just accumulates and
accumulates and accumulates and it dries
causing them quite a lot of
um it can even cause infertility
cause many issues
I visited doctors almost every single
month and I was examined almost every
single month and I think for the first
two years I was never examined
um
they never examine my genitalia they
just put it down to stomach pain okay so
I thought okay you know if they say or
not then that's fine so your mother
because you were young your mother or
your parents were taking you to the
doctor yeah but they weren't
saying no potentially it might be it
might be that yeah it's quite strange
that in a way that they would they would
they were willing to say look this is
causing a problem but then they wouldn't
address because I don't think they put
that together I see right I don't think
this is what I mean they don't I don't
think they necessarily believe that
because they have never had that type of
complication then why is my child having
that type of application so they don't
put two and two together okay
and um
when I was 14 years old I started
physically tearing because this is Hill
Scar Tissue now okay so I started
physically tearing
um from the bottom upwards and but only
like a tiny tiny bit and urination
became even more painful
period pain became
you know
well I figured my period pain stayed the
same I can't say that it was it was
worsened but because of the stinging the
pain
um that's a different type of pain so
you have the period pain plus you have a
unhealed wound yeah and you know you
have a ripping plus you have to urinate
every day so it's it takes a very long
time for it to physically heal you know
given the fact that it's your body is
very active
and I was taken again to a doctor I was
taken to a female Doctor Who physically
examined my genitalia and she basically
explained to my mother that because I
have really sensitive skin
it like was tearing it needed a way out
the blood and it would start tearing
through my skin because again if you
remember I told you it was drying yeah
so it physically tore through my skin
opening it bit by bit every day
and then it would stop but but did that
doctor so did that doctor acknowledge
the FGM then yeah they saw it they just
they were like oh here's some
painkillers
um it's the period that's causing it
that's it so do you think they knew what
had happened to you yeah yeah right so
they they looked at it and you think
they just thought oh that's just a
culture they understood it was a
cultural thing that happened to some
people and they were like well here's
some painkillers yeah okay because just
to be clear to anyone
um listening FGM is illegal isn't it it
is illegal yeah
um there's the
um
female genital mutilation Act of 2003
yeah
um I believe
I came in 2001 so even after it became
illegal as well my I was examined but I
don't think it was public knowledge
I think it was just you know starting
out as you know this massive concern
okay but even then I was examined
multiple times from the age of 14
onwards
um but I remember I
before the tearing I remember I was
because I think earlier you asked me
when did I know yeah something was wrong
I was in year six and I sat down
um in a sex education lesson and I
signed the permission form myself
because I knew my mother wouldn't let me
oh wow really
um and I really wanted to be so you
forged her significance because you
wanted to understand right okay okay I
wanted to understand what it was and
because she was so adamant for me not to
do it I I faked her I knew her signature
so I just signed her name
and I sat in class and I remember them
showing the male genitalia and the
female
and then I looked at the female and I
thought I couldn't even care I've never
seen male jeans I could I did not care
yeah
but the female one I was so focused on
that one and even the fact that my
teacher didn't pick that up or
um like I was just so confused because
it looked what it should look like but
for me I was like
that's disgusting you know why why do
you have all of them bits I don't
you know that's what we were cons what
was considered dirty and unattractive or
just not good
so I was like
every bad thing that was said about the
Western World I believed in that moment
because I thought
they're so unclean
right so so prior to that moment had you
thought that FGM happened here as well
yeah but then that moment you realized
it hadn't yeah and so for you it was
like
oh yeah all the rumors are true it's
disgusting and dirty wow okay that's and
I was like the females here are you know
they must be disgusting yeah okay
um you know wear cleaner and yeah but
then I quickly quickly quickly realized
after high school
um not after high school during High
School
um that FGM was a crime
and that it should have never happened
um and I think when I found that out I
realized
it's not that I realized I think all the
insecurities came flooding in
um you know knowing that it just doesn't
happen to everybody knowing that this
was wrong from the beginning and even
though as kids we knew it was wrong
because it was painful you know it
wasn't fun it wasn't something to be
excited about we were tricked
um so you start going back in your mind
and thinking
you know yeah now that makes sense now
this makes sense now this makes sense
but then it leaves us with
you know resenting our family members
not being able to trust our family
members feeling abnormal in some cases
and how did you find that out when you
say you left high school and you
realized it was it was wrong and it was
a crime what was the trigger for finding
that out I think
um I really don't remember but I think
it was in high school a young another
young friend of mine also went through
the same thing but she came here where
she was really really young so it
happened to her
when she was maybe two three years old
so
she was very open right about it I
always kept you know I was told to keep
my mouth shut so I kept my mouth shut
but with her she was so open and I
remember telling her but it was you know
isn't it isn't a good thing
and she's like no it's not they lie to
us
this is this is not right you should
have never been done it's not even an
Islamic practice
and I think knowing that I thought I
felt so betrayed Yeah by my family yeah
I felt like now I'm not normal everybody
else in my school was normal and I
wasn't normal
and I didn't know who was circumcised
you know I I say circumcised because
that's the term they use
um but I didn't know who had FGM and who
didn't
you know so you feel embarrassed
so embarrassed I never told a teacher I
was so ashamed
and I just thought everyone is gonna
think you're damaged or you know because
you were still shots
um and when you face the reality of what
a vagina actually looks like you think
whoa okay mine does not look like that
and
you you know you start putting yourself
down and within my family they had a
really bad habit of calling me
and
I think it's just as they didn't mean it
just to clarify like was it a kind of in
a family jokes way or you know in the
way that they actually were doing it as
a to put you down and I think it was to
put me down but it was more so a normal
thing to say to girls okay it just you
know it just flows it just comes out so
I don't think it was intentional I think
you know when they get frustrated or
angry they're like oh you know whatever
um but the way that we use those
terminologies is more casual than
insults obviously coming to this country
and being educated we know now that
that's an insult you know before he was
like oh it's just something parents say
and one time I thought to myself you
know as a teenager is it because they
thought that I was going to be
oh so they caught me because quickly you
start to realize that you know it's to
prevent girls from sex outside marriage
and and I thought did they think that I
was going to do that and that's why they
did it
and I'm like you know it just really
really puts my self self-esteem was gone
um I had lacked confidence I was I had
mood swings
um and then I was labeled as the
Troublemaker I wasn't learning like
everybody else
um I struggled with English and with
reading I guess
um
because also at the point when you're a
teenager is when you start to think
about relationships as well even a very
low level gentle subtle level but that
must have had a huge impact on you
thinking about what if people find out
if about that you know will I be able to
date people they I I they in was not in
my mind to be honest I did date but it's
not the you know the common
well it could be but I would my dating
was speaking to them I was never I could
never
have someone physically touch me like
that in a sexual way anyway because in
the back of my mind I knew what was
happening down there so I just thought I
didn't want anyone to find out my
disgusting secrets you know and then it
became my disgusting secret so I didn't
tell anyone even the guys that I used to
date back in high school and talked to
and my friends and you know and I just I
didn't ever talk about it I acted as if
you know I am normal knowing that you
know that I had this procedure done and
I was suffering in silence
but that was the only thing I knew how
to do
okay I am
I know that the there's another big part
of your story as well which I'm gonna
which it's
um are you happy if we move on to that
of course yeah great um do you feel like
you've said everything you want to say
about that period because we'll do a
summary at the end yes but do you think
is there anything else from that period
that you think is important for people
to know what I think it's important for
people to know that from the time I came
to the UK up to when I left to go back
to Somalia the topic we're just about to
discuss after
um I have visited doctors multiple times
I've been examined multiple times and
I've been sent home multiple times
and it was really disheartening to know
that
I didn't have the support of medical
professionals in terms of
um you know defibrillation exists now
which is opening that wound up but that
wasn't that was never an option for
someone as young as myself so we then
saw that as you just want us to stay
shut so you're okay with it as well
because you examinated you sent me home
well you're right yeah you know so
it felt like I was trapped in two
different societies that I was a part of
but I wasn't allowed to be either one
you know the Western World wanted me to
come you know be more Western and the
Somalian one wanted to be more Somali
and so as you get lost in the middle
um what should they have done for anyone
watching you know we could have a doctor
watching who
looks at somebody who has a similar
condition what should that person do I
think that you should really consider
person-centered Care One not all
survivors are the same
um not to experiences are the same
um so support that person in the way
they want to be supported do not allow
them to live with the same discomfort
that they came in with you know have a
solution for them at hand I know that
defibrillation now is an option for
people who are not pregnant where before
it was only for pregnant women
um which is quite shocking to be honest
with you why not help them before they
get pregnant you know
um
but now that that is an option I think
um a lot doctors and nurses any
professional that has a duty of care
that comes across a Survivor needs to do
their job in providing the service that
they came and asked you for it's as
simple as that yeah
very clear and understandable I hope so
it doesn't sound like rocket science
does it no it's sort of amazing that
that was never an option that was given
to you even for somebody to say
are you okay with all that you know yeah
just to ask you if yeah okay
um okay so let's move on to the next
chapter okay
um what age are you when you decided to
go back to Somali to reconnect I was 17
17. okay so did you you finished sixth
form or high school no I didn't start I
started but because
of my insecurities and my doubts and my
trauma
um I was again like I said I was labeled
a bad child someone who did not conform
to you know the Somalian norms
so I knew of this culture that we have
called Ellis and it means to reculture
okay so because I used to hear it
growing up and I've I know siblings and
cousins not siblings but cousins and
relatives who were sent back to Somalia
I thought instead of them sending me
back let me you know offer that up and
be a good child to my parents you know
prove that I can be responsible and you
know I want to get to know my country
and
I was very naive to say the least
I expected the best I don't know why but
if you think about it even though in
Somalia the FGM was really bad
that is the only
um and something has happened but the
only two bad things happened to me in
the whole time that I was there
so I remembered the good things
you know the going to play with my
siblings and being so free and climbing
trees and causing trouble it was very
fun you know my siblings uh cousins and
all and I guess at that age if you're if
you're a kind of teenager you're looking
for acceptance aren't you if you feel
different from where you are right now
in the UK you're going to think maybe I
can find Acceptance in the other place
where I share my culture I was actually
hoping that my family would accept me
more yeah if I you know
said that I'm gonna do this for them and
you know for myself
and um
I went back to Somalia still thinking
that I was that six-year-old kid and
they're gonna treat me the way that they
treated me then but I was a grown-ass
woman the treatment I didn't realize was
going to be completely different to when
I was a child
um so I told my mother that's what I
wanted to do at first she was really
really concerned because um al-shabab
was there
and they ruled majority of the country
just for anyone who might not know can
you explain who they what they are
al-shabab is a terrorist organization
quite similar to Isis and Al-Qaeda
they are very very dangerous and very
very very ruthless
um
I don't know if I could say but I I
can't stand them
um but when I left here and my mom was
trying to explain that I thought my
people can't do this again I was so
naive and I thought it was just the
Western world that was trying to portray
my country in this way
and I thought no nothing's gonna happen
to me I'll be fine I promise so she
agreed
I think majority of my family were very
grateful that I had
um you know suggested
the reculturing and was this had you
been while you've been living in the UK
and growing up in UK had you been going
back for Summers or visits or was this
like a so you so this was just a like
after a decade away coming back
reconnecting with the the aunties and
and all those those the land yeah wow
okay
and my mom booked our flight we went to
Dubai spent two weeks there bought me
gifts and then we went to Somalia where
I got dropped off and then my mom came
back to the UK along with my passport
she took your passport back to the UK
yes oh why did she do that that's what
happens with back and Ellis they take
your passport
um but with my Mom the reason that she
gave because I asked is because one I'm
very very forgetful I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm not gonna sit here I'm like I am
very very forgetful and she didn't want
me to lose it in that country because
anyone else can use it and to come you
know in my place because there was a
terrorist organization there as well if
anyone had you know my passport then
that would also cause a risk to myself
and here and she would get into trouble
so I think she was trying to protect
myself
um and keep it safe yeah right okay that
was the idea and then I was handed over
to my auntie who's also called shamsa
and I stayed with her for three months
but I remember the first
three days it was so surreal you know
everything was so different to what I
grew up in here
and I remember her coming up to me one
day and the girls were you know looked
like they were going somewhere I'm like
where's everyone going
and everyone seemed to have you know be
going in the same direction I'm like
where's everyone going
so they said oh there's something called
tashir as I was tashir and it basically
means when al-shabab decided to punish
someone for a crime everyone in that
town has to come and watch
too yeah yeah and this is Men Women and
Children
and men were lined up on one side women
were lined up on this side and my auntie
begged me not to go and I said if you
want me to believe that my people are
capable of this then I will go because I
used to see this on TV yeah I need to
see with my own eyes I wish I didn't go
I really wish I didn't go
um I got there and I don't know how but
I ended up in the front of the line
because everyone was so scared they were
kind of like oh
pushing back
and they brought the man out nailed him
down and then I found out that he was
going to have his hand cut off
and there were men and wearing
balaclavas and they stretched out his
hand took a large machete and they
literally I think with three Cuts they
completely severed his hand oh God and
then they took the middle finger whilst
everybody's chanting Allahu Akbar and
just waved across and these are little
babies and little kids running around
and watching this as well teenagers
young people
and they waved around across the men
section and then they gave it to the
women and then the women waved the right
past me
um and the other women his mother was
forced to watch as well oh God and she
collapsed and they did they bought a jar
of that contained
um like boiling hot oil and they took
his hand that was just severed and they
put it in the oil
took it out quickly and then he passed
out his arm that was seven yeah so they
did not the not the seven hand not his
actual wrist yeah the wrist yeah the
hand was seven but the wrist that was
bleeding to like cauterize it yeah yeah
that's what it seemed like to me and
then they wrapped it really quickly and
then because he passed out they kind of
dragged him
out of there and I remember my cousin
whilst they were chanting but I wasn't I
was just an utter shock and disbelief
and she was like you need to say and
I'll say what and she goes you need to
say but I said I will not
say that because I'm not using the name
of God especially one that I know is
peaceful
and for this I said no I'm not going to
do that because by then I've been
educated on terrorism and also Islam
and um I said I'm not going to do it and
she goes okay so I I kind of like
like move my mouth
um so that they would think because she
said to me if I don't then they can whip
maybe they had this really long whip and
guns and things so they were like
they're gonna either beat you up or whip
you if you don't say it so I started
moving my mouth went back to my auntie's
house and
I cried I was I was terrified of
everyone including my own family because
I thought are you are you obviously they
weren't but when something is normal
yeah you know it's everyone accepts it
so I I didn't know who was who and what
was what
um but again I trusted my auntie this
wasn't uh my this the FGM was my my
father's mother's side so it was my
father's side this particular family was
my mother's side who've never wronged me
in their lives so I trusted them but
were you saying to them that was awful
are you scared to express that you
thought no I told that right one thing
about me is I always express myself
unless I was in danger okay
um but I expect I was like this is
horrific why would they do this and she
was like you need to stay low you know
if they find out you're a British
citizen that can really harm you they
can even kidnap you because they were
kidnapping girls at the time
um so there were quite a lot of girls at
um risk so
I think three months into it I get a
call from my mom and she's like oh my
brother in another city wants to come
visit you and he wants to take you to
that family because my mom didn't have
any brothers or sisters that were the
same mom and dad so it's either from her
mom's side or from her dad's side got
you and I was with my aunties from my
mom's dad's side and
um
my uncle from my mom's mom's side was
coming to come pick me up
so he came and he was lovely at first
and he picked me up and he took me to a
small city called Marca
the whole entire Journey from where I
lived Boulevard
was like it was a very long journey I
think it was
uh two nights or something like that it
was a very very long journey and it was
by car
and we had to you know stay in different
people's houses as a rest stop
and then I was taken to Marca
but again during that journey I was
treated like a princess right you know I
was given everything I asked for I was
being taken into Farms Fruit Farms which
are absolutely incredible
and I was just like oh you know I'm so
lucky to have a family although the
place I lived was really dangerous I
thought you know I have a family that
will help me explore you know
and
when we got there
things changed quite rapidly
I think everyone had their own plans in
mind for my coming
and there was really horrible intentions
behind him coming to pick me up
okay so do you think that
do you think that the intentions were
there from the beginning yeah it was
planned and definitely okay right well
let's get into that
um
you you got there
presumably at that point you were
thinking okay this is good this is nice
I've had this nice couple of days
experience with the family you arrive at
this house and then what's the point
where you realize okay I'm not sure
about this he comes to me one day and
he's like this is my uncle your uncle
yes after being there for a week he
comes to me and he's like champsa you
know I really
um think it would be beneficial for you
to think about marriage
and I said to him you know I have no
intentions of getting married that's not
why I came here
um that's not what I want to do so I
thought saying no would have been enough
yeah and
at first he left it and then he just
continuously almost every single day
just making small small suggestions and
then the suggestions kind of turned into
you know firm suggestions it was a lot
more firmer
um and his tone has changed and he
became very very scary to me I saw red
flags wow and then
I got he got a phone call one day and he
goes champ said come here so he gives me
the phone and it's my auntie his sister
who was in a city that I passed and she
never said two words to me she knew I
was there never came to see me and she
goes oh you know I would love you I
would love to introduce you to my son
um I want you to meet him you know and
you just if you guys like each other you
can get married and again I said to her
on that first phone call yeah and I said
no but this is why I knew it was
premeditated I knew that it would there
was a plan before he even got me
and um I said no I'm not interested so
because it was so consistent the um the
ask of getting married you know get
married get married get married
then one day I went to him and I said if
you're so desperate for me to get
married because I got really scared at
that at that point
I said I was talking to someone who I
wasn't even talking to him really he was
a friend of mine and he lived in the in
my auntie's place where I was staying
previously
so I suggested him I was like if you're
gonna force me to get married at least
you know someone like you know someone I
know and someone I've met I said him he
took the phone and just for suggesting
it I got beaten the hell out of
hit me up really bad
and she's a grown man this is a grown-up
man yeah wow I was 17 at the time and
before that had you seen any sign of
physical abuse like that Jesse's tone
changed before that but he's never got
physical with me but because of the
suggestion it was like all his plans
were falling apart
because of my one suggestion
so the asking of for me to get married
was not asking anymore it was more
threats and it's going to happen and I
suppose at that point you've been driven
two days away it's not like you can just
go I'm gonna fly home you've got no
passport yeah no way of getting to the
airport yeah no I didn't even have a he
took my phone from at that point so I
had nothing
um and this didn't happen straight away
it was like weeks into it yeah
um when by the time we got to a month of
me being there it turned into threats so
one of the threats was al-shabab the
terrorist organization ruled Marca
that's particular City and because it
was so small is in between mountains and
water so government decided not to
invade because everyone in that small
City would die there's nowhere for
people to escape
so
one of his threats was I'm going to call
al-shabab and I will get you locked up
for being an asiwalidine which means
um
someone who's bad to their parent we're
not allowed to talk back to our parents
that or that we are considered bad if we
do even if we're in the right
um and in the prisons the sentence is
three months for that
and in those prisons women tend to get
sexually assaulted right and when I
heard about the things that go on in
those prisons because people have just
volunteered this information to you I
was terrified
and I thought I can't because I will die
they will kill me and plus I'm a British
citizen so they will have a field day
with that one
um so I thought okay I need to minimize
all of the you know big mouth that I
have I have to keep my true self in
and just
just agree to everything they say from
this point onwards survival mode I was
on survival mode
and then one day I got a call from my
mom he got a call from my mom and
because I didn't have a phone access to
a phone he just said oh you know you can
call me and you can speak to her and he
sat me down put the phone onto my mom
and she was like oh Uncle told me that
you wanted to get married you found a
nice boy
um and they told him that it was his
sister's son and she was like I've never
met him but he seems like um a nice
person obviously this is anyone that my
sister raises good
I I could not say anything because I
knew if I did once I got off the phone
he will beat the out of me
so I said yeah but in my 17 year old
mind I was trying to find a way to
escape so I thought just say yeah now
you know then there's no risk to me
being beaten so I can try to devise a
plan for me to escape
I my mother bought me a camera I sold it
um my friends from London two teenage
girls the same age as me tried to
collected money to send to me I think it
was a hundred dollars
but that wasn't enough to get out
because there was absolutely no way out
if I drove if I went by car there's
checkpoints everywhere one of his other
my uncles other threats was I'm gonna
put your picture in every single
checkpoint from there to the city where
um it was government controlled
so I was like okay I can't even leave
because this man is you know threatening
to take my photo and put it everywhere
I can't take a flight because there's no
airport I can't go see because I can't
swim so I was trapped to say uh to say
that I was trapped as an understatement
one day I was in the toilet and I get a
knock on my back the bathroom door and
they're like hurry up hurry up hurry up
so I quickly got dressed came into the
room
um I was escorted into a room my uncle
was in and there was some young man sat
next to him so I was told to sit down
there's a plate of food that I haven't
seen
you know this this was the same type of
presentation I had when I first arrived
yeah and
um he was like oh me Hassan Hassan was
his name
um till this day I don't know his last
name I'm not gonna lie to you I have
never been told his last name so I I
don't know even though his family I
don't know because like I said my
mother's siblings are very
so we didn't know our cousins like that
especially back home he introduces him
and he says this is the person I want
you to get married to and I was like oh
whoa and he explains this artist's son
so in my mind I'm thinking my first
cousin it's my blood yeah and I said I'm
not interested in getting married and I
said that out loud I said I don't want
to get married in front of the boys yeah
yeah I said I don't want to get married
because I thought maybe if I say that
then he would not want to do it as well
and then my uncle was like oh don't
worry don't worry you know you'll come
around
and I thought okay like this is actually
getting
um serious now like this because did
getting married means staying there
forever in their houses is either that
or
I think they they had hope that I would
bring him here I I see right because I
carry a British passport and that's very
valuable back in Somalia
um so
I just I just could not get over the
fact that he bought this man from you
know a vet it was very far it was like
miles away from the city that I started
with
so I thought okay and when you say this
man how old was he oh wow okay I didn't
tell you that part
um the way that my uncle explained it is
that he was actually two years younger
than me oh that's the way he explained
it 15. yeah but
I know for a fact that
there are a lot of Somalian people who
either have quite a lot of children we
don't keep track of birthdays okay so I
think it's a guessing game right right
um so he
that's the easiest maths ever but in my
mind it just I just could not
calculate what was happening and then I
said to him two years younger than me I
said no like that's even worse yeah you
know I said no no but he was not two
years younger than me he if anything was
older than me he was huge like it makes
no it makes no sense it was like a
proper built right man
[Music]
um
you know it just I don't know I can't
really speak for his age
um I didn't give birth to him so I don't
know that's just what I was told
um
I continue to say no no no no no
um and then
I get a few weeks later
um after being trying to again being
threatened to be in
beaten trying to you know find a way to
escape and my
eight 17 year old man just could not
figure a way out
um no communication was the outside
world I didn't know how to contact the
British Embassy I didn't even know
whether they would help me or not
um so I just
you know I was just on survival mode
every single day
and with al-shabab they terrified me
enough for me to just
be quiet because I did not want to end
up dead they've killed too many people
by then
and then I get a call I remember I was
at my mom's best friend's house and I
get a call from my father who was here
in the UK
and he basically is congratulating me oh
no on my marriage I'm like what
and I was like what do you mean he goes
oh you know you're a married woman now
I'm like how the is that possible
you know because I was waiting for the
shift they're like the actual man who
marries us to call me yeah so that I can
say no again like I was waiting for
someone to listen to my no but I never
got that call and I didn't even know
that that it was happening that day they
kept it from me
so when I got the call from my father
everything was already done
even though that marriage under Islamic
law is not a valid marriage but so
there's been no ceremony and you'd give
there was no concept and there was no
consent no so the mejer is like what you
guys might consider the engagement right
but it's an actual marriage there's no
engagement we don't do engagements and
things like that
I was married off
and my father in that phone call said
what's his name
what's the boy's name who are his family
what are their names what tribacy and I
said to my father so you know I didn't
say it actually I was like you didn't
know you don't know his first name or
last name he's like no
and it shocked me
bear in mind I was so let down by my
family because of the FGM and then to
have been let down by them again through
beating and threats and now my own
father
had given me up as if I was just you
know damaged goods I thought there was a
serious problem with me maybe they saw
something that I did not see
and
I hanged up the phone on him because I
just could not process what was
happening but I wasn't even given a
chance to process what was happening I
had women come to the house they put me
in a green dress and this whole entire
time I was in the days yeah like I was
so confused as to what's what was
happening and I thought this can't be
real this can't be real this can't be
real and I remember after they put this
white makeup on me like it was I look
like a ghost because it wasn't my
Foundation color and
they put you know they did my hair put
so many pins in it it hurts
um at least I have something else to
focus on they put me in the back of a
car and this whole time I haven't seen
him
they put him in the back of the car
drove me around town everyone is singing
and clapping and
excited and I'm just
you know in the days I'm not none of I'm
not paying attention to my surroundings
at all I was just in the days and then
they brought me back to the house and my
uncle's house there were women there
everyone was dancing drinking eating
and I was just numb because I knew I was
going to be locked in a bedroom with
this man oh is that the next bit yeah so
I was absolutely numb I felt sick to my
stomach I remember they presented me
with so much clothes and fake jewelry
and
um the bed that they had bought was
second hand all the clothes that was in
front of me that were supposedly gifts
was actually puts in debt under my name
so it was my debt to pay off
so the whole entire motive true motive
came out and that was money
take stock money from my mother
because she lived in the UK and they
didn't and so she was rich she was
richer you know money just falls out of
the trees and comes out of walls you
know
um Without You prompting it once all of
that was done
I was put into a room and I remember the
bed was facing a mirror so they just lit
if it was so surreal I was it was as if
I was carried it didn't feel like I was
walking it felt like I was walking but
it felt as if I wasn't like I was right
like floating yeah I was being you know
just I was floating in but I was being
guided in
I'm just just because because of the
previous bit we've talked about with the
FGM were you still a virgin at this
point I was yes I was although a lot of
people had doubts I was yeah okay
because that presumably that must have
been a frightening thing as well yeah
because you've never you didn't know how
that was going to affect yeah the
marriage okay 100 but thank you for
reminding me because prior to me being
put in that room prior to the wedding I
think a week prior
um I remember because I knew how serious
they were about the marriage I thought
because al-shabab is there if they take
my
um
do you know how I explained when I was
14 I was ripping yes they took that as
me losing my virginity then I would be
stoned to death oh God so I was like all
right that I might as well you know tell
her what happens so she can speak to my
mom so I don't die you know so I told my
auntie
and my uncle's wife she called my mother
my mother explained and I I think
without my mother's knowledge she took
me to a Qatar
and I was there to be examined to see
whether I was a virgin or not
because everyone had no faith in me
and when she checked that she was like
yeah yeah she's she's still a virgin
because again the stitches were like
that much it came off
and then
um she looked at me
and she goes to stitching you back up I
said hell no did you you just confirmed
it for me I'm a virgin browser
thank you so much I said bye take care
close my legs together put my things on
and I walked out before they can even
resist that
but I did ask why would I do that and
she goes for your husband so ah so he
can rip me open I said no thank you no
thank you
um so when I was put into the room I had
that conversation playing in my head
and I thought to myself imagine if he
thinks that I'm not a virgin because
some people don't have a a hymen yeah so
I was like what if even though she just
confirmed it I was like but what if what
if what if
and I remember I was facing a mirror and
I was still trying to figure a way out
even though there was no way out I was
now point to that room I'm trapped
I I still was trying to figure out how
how do I get out how do I live
and then he comes into the room and
without saying hi are you okay what's
going on he dropped he's wearing a um a
material that they just wrap around yeah
we call it Maurice he was wearing that
and he
just came in and right in front of the
mirror that I was looking at because
again I was just daydreaming
he just he dropped it
and because of the type of person I am
and the way that it happened I didn't
know whether to laugh or cry okay
and I say this all the time I genuinely
do not know which way to go because I
thought the way it happened the way he
did it was so ridiculous like it was
like it was like I laugh at everything
so it was like what the almost and
but then I thought oh I know
exactly what he wants and what the what
am I gonna do so hit butt naked I told
him okay please take this pin out of my
head because you know I don't want to be
touched with all of this on me and then
he's there taken up because there were a
lot of pins so I was just trying to
slowly act like oh I was trying to take
my time
um try to give myself time to find out
to figure out a way to escape but that
was never going to happen
and once that was done
I thought to myself
whilst he was actually in the process of
taking off I thought something you have
two choices
as at 18 actually I was I need to stop
saying I was something after I turned 18
is when they got married
and I thought to myself you have two
choices either be raped tonight
or submit and just tell them to off
tomorrow
so
I thought okay let me get it over and
down with and then when it started again
because of the FGM I would I was not I
did not have defibrillation which means
I was still shots
um
on top of you know all the other pain
and that I endured I was just I was
terrified
but it was the pain was so overwhelming
my whole entire body hurt and the
stitches are slowly you know being
ripped apart
and then I said stop you know I don't I
can't do it anymore I couldn't breathe
like I was crying I was in pain
and then the moment I think I tried to
you know get him to stop I was just
pinned down and he used all his force
and his might
um and then I was raped that night and
three nights after that until
so I spent seven days in that in that
room
because like your seven days honeymoon
you can either leave to do your wadu
which is to get ready for prayer you
pray in your room you eat in your room
you shower you come back in your room
you don't leave at all he can leave
sometimes but you can't leave
was he talking to you and and he was was
it just no it was just no no because I
refused to speak okay and then he felt
worried that you're upset or you're just
his now so yeah I was I was his property
basically
and then
so like I said I spent seven nights
there
um
out of the seven nights I was raped for
four right and then on the fourth day I
just could not take it anymore and I
said to him if you touch me again then I
will kill you like I will actually kill
you and I don't care whether I die they
could kill me if they want if you touch
me I will find something and I will hurt
you
and I don't know why that scared him
um but because of the amount of pain I
was in I was unable to urinate for three
days actually not for three days I
wasn't able to urinate for the period of
time that I was in that marriage yeah
um and with him there so what had
happened is he caused so much internal
trauma that it affected my urination
so I couldn't the urine would not come
out it would come out a little bit and
it would shoot back inside so I used to
like literally lay down on a dirty uh
toilet because we didn't have toilet
seats and things like that it's just a
hole in the ground I used to lay down
because I was in that much pain
and they refused to give me any medical
help because it costs money and you know
they don't want to spend money
and once the seven days was done he
my uncle actually kicked us out of my my
grandma's house and I used the money
that I collected from the camera and the
one that my friend sent me to rent a
property so I thought that's my house
you know I'm I'm the boss I'm the owner
no you're not
uh he was in there I'm thinking yeah
because he's the husband
he's the boss you've gone through this
horrific process and you've now moved
into a property with your husband that
you're paying for but he's ultimately
the boss of at what point did you think
okay this has to end how long had it
been before you were like I need to get
out of here oh my God it's been months
oh months yeah oh wow it was months
before
I think when I had my breaking point was
on top of the rape I was also being
beaten by him so domestic violence yeah
I was involved and it was brutal so
anytime I didn't do anything I would be
beaten and the last time he beat me was
so severe that I just could not I did
not care whether I lived or died anymore
and I called my mother and I said is
this what you wanted for me for your
family to abuse me forced me to get
married and now I didn't tell her about
the rape because I wanted to wait until
I saw how scared she wouldn't believe me
I want to look her in the eye
um
but I told her that he was beating me
and my mother hates anybody laying a
finger on us yeah and she just could not
comprehend it and I said your family
will lie to you as they have done for
the past few months I said if I die here
is all of user's fault
and I think when she heard that she did
everything in her power to get me out so
because the family weren't listening and
they were like oh you know they're just
a married couple they'll be fine they
were trying to justify it my mom wasn't
having any of it
um so me and her hatched a plan for me
to escape and that plan was
um
for me to catch a bus
covered from head to toe and use my pain
as a reason to be going to a hospital
but not go to the hospital just take a
um a car and leave and I knew a woman
who worked at the hospital who helped me
previously because they wouldn't take me
and so I said to her if my family come
at any time it doesn't matter what time
it is just say she just left then they
would still think that I'm there
so they said okay she said okay I
remember I got into the car and my
auntie the shamsa and the other one was
waiting for me in Mogadishu so by then
my mom told them what had happened and
she said go and get my child but they
couldn't come to this side because he
had it was terrorism they were scared so
they had to wait on that side oh the
cheat so your mom told them she's
escaping going yeah yeah so you'd set
off in the car in in basically like I
guess like it was a bus yeah full of
people and were you wearing like a
nicarbos yeah yeah I was wearing in the
club I was wearing a big hijab which is
like the big black cloth I was wearing
gloves I was wearing socks I was
absolutely terrified and I remember I
kept asking God please save me please
save me I'll never do anything bad in my
life you know I just please save me and
ultimately actually before I left one of
my uncles went right past the window and
I Oh I thought I was gonna get cold
if you got caught trying to escape I
wouldn't be sat here today wow I can
tell you that I would not be sat here
today
and then once I got to modishu
um where my auntie was my aunties were
waiting for me they took me to their
house but still I was so afraid of
everyone yeah because I thought you guys
would probably do the same if you had a
chance
um but I remember he actually called my
the small phone that I had
and he was like uh
um my auntie picked up and he was like
who's this and she said shamsa because
Champs is her name just like me yeah and
he's like he thought it was me he was
talking to and he's like watch when I
find you I'm gonna put you in prison you
will not leave this country I'll make
sure of it and Monty was like actually
Champs is not the person you're speaking
to you're speaking to her auntie the
person she was named after and she goes
all of these empty threats of yours she
goes well how about stop behind it stop
hiding behind al-shabab
you know they couldn't go there so she
said why don't you come here and show us
what you're capable of and we'll show
you what we are capable of
this is our daughter you know you messed
up big time and now you want to threaten
her
and she was like if you step foot and
move the show I will shoot you myself
and he was like oh I'm so sorry I didn't
know it was you and he goes but it was
okay for you to talk to my niece like
that
he never called after that
um they knew that I had left
successfully the uncle's never called No
I refuse even if you had I still
wouldn't have ever spoken to him I I
haven't till this day to be honest
and then a few weeks later I had my
brother come to the country to bring me
my passport and a flight ticket but come
to find out nobody in my family apart
from my mother wanted me to come back
here
each and every one of them let me just
say my mother was the whole time I was
there she was diagnosed and she was
suffering from a brain tumor
I didn't know she told everyone to keep
it from me because I'm an emotional
person and she didn't want me to go
crazy because I had a
attachment to her so she didn't want me
to that's the word she used she said I
didn't I don't want my daughter to lose
her mind so she's already under a lot of
pressure leave her until she comes here
I was
told whilst I was on the plane that my
mother was dying and that she had stage
four cancer oh God which meant that by
the time I got back to the UK my mother
was in a coma I left her healthy I came
back to her and on her deathbed and this
is the woman who for months on end was
begging
for someone to go and get me
before she died and I had a conversation
with her one day and she said if I die
here and I just thought she was just a
mom thing she was if I die here whilst
you're there I want you to know that you
will also die there
and I was like yeah I know because
there's bombs and bullets flying over my
head so I just thought she was you know
being
just a warrior parent I didn't I didn't
think that she quite literally meant
that
so she did everything she could until
she went into that coma to ensure
my return and that was the second time
wasn't it because the first time when
she brought you over
from the when you're a child the second
time she said yeah
so okay as you can imagine I just went
through something horrific I need to
have to come back I had to push all of
that aside
and now grieve for someone I have not
seen for a year
and I thought you know I just kept
thinking I wish I knew I wish I had
known I wish I had known because I
blamed her quite a lot whilst I was
there so why is this happening to me
it's her family but I didn't know that
she was dealing with a brain tumor
and my mother died exactly seven days
after my return how did you get to where
you are now what was the Turning Point
what do you do now
I am a educator I am a public speaker
um I
um have been I've had the pleasure of
working with different charities here in
the UK in terms of honorabase violence
as a whole
um including FGM
I support survivors
um on a daily basis you know
um
I also did a campaign with the mayor of
London's office and I would like to
make some changes within the NHS in
terms of offering us better support with
the complications that we have to live
through it's not just and the practice
also support the survivors you know
we're living with these instrumental
mental health issues and these physical
complications help us you know there
should be something under the NHS that
doesn't involve just opening you up
leaving your damaged you know damaged
nerves and Scar Tissue there should be a
lot more available for us you know we
shouldn't have to suffer
and um I work I help to train met police
officers on the practice of FGM
um I've been doing that for I believe
two months I did it
[Music]
twice now and is one of the best
experiences I have ever had
and it made me realize that quite a lot
of people are not educated on the topic
they don't know what type of language to
use when talking to survivors and they
don't know how to approach it they don't
know whether they
um they mostly they say we're trying to
be culturally sensitive stop being
culturally sensitive okay if you want to
ask a question ask a question you know
otherwise there is no Avenue for you to
learn if you don't ask the tough
questions and you know there are people
like me that can answer those tough
questions but you need to understand
there are people that cannot so you need
to know who can and who can't you know
um
but I also play a massive part in trying
to end it within my community
because I don't want anyone ever ever
ever going through anything that I have
not just the fgma but everything else
um understandably and when you and when
you look when you look back over your
life which is I mean you've got some
in terms of me talking to you your
experiences are
unbelievable but sadly it sounds like
there's lots of people that will have
shared your experiences in the world but
when you look back over your life so far
you're still young what's something you
think you've learned
I learned never to silence my voice ever
again
I think I found so much peace
and one I removed myself completely from
that toxic environment that I was in
which gave me enough room to grow
to have Ambitions to have dreams to
reprogram my mind so that I'm able to
raise my daughter in a healthy happy
environment so she doesn't ever have to
go through any of the insecurities any
of the abuse that I went through
my daughter is very well aware of what
FGM is she actually helps me educate
people other people like her school for
example
um so she's very proud of me and I'm so
so proud of her
but being a mom now
it made me realize yo like it's really
not that hard to be kind you know you
did not have to do any of that what what
is amazing about you genuinely is you're
one of the people that broke the cycle
because when you were talking about the
start of it you're talking generations
of people in the same cycle never ending
yeah never ending cycle and you're one
of the people that has broken it and
your daughter won't enter a cycle like
that you're an amazing Storyteller I
mean it makes my job so easy I just sit
here going oh wow oh wow because if I
don't do it that way then I'll I'll cry
and who wants that well that's the thing
you you tell it in a very engaging way
despite the fact it's a very very or
like difficult topic to listen to
because I don't like it triggering me or
triggering me if I you know if I don't
laugh Okay so
a happy place you're a genuinely amazing
and inspirational person and
um I'm so honored to sit here and talk
to you today and um really do wish you
all the best Champs thank you
for the life I've had
people feel young how old are you I'm
like in my sick maybe 60s oh you feel
like you're in your 60s okay 80s
yeah but I'm 30 I 10 30 a lot this week
actually oh happy birthday thank you wow
thank you brilliant oh my God it's
another shocking issue because in Korea
you weren't allowed to put the newspaper
in the bin I guess yeah never never
thought if you just put the bin your own
families public executions or send the
political presence so we never talked
about that wow